tom and ann are on a date i know what do
you mean you know how do you
know cause
i set them up
i was watching anne with tom at the
dance
and she seemed to be having a good time
so i went over and talked to her what
are you looking for in a date anyway
i don't know what does anyone want just
a nice funny guy who
likes me and treats me well tom's funny
and he treat you well ha-ha i'm serious
you want a good date why not ask out the
only guy that's made you smile tonight
he's ridiculous all that dumb swagger
it's an act
he's sweet you should just ask him out
for a drink a thousand percent sure he'd
say yes
i bet you guys would have a good
time man i need to like wrap my head
around this why it makes sense to me
this is a small loser town with loser
people
tom's like at least semi-cool you know
what i'm hearing
you tried to make anne happy for
valentine's day
oh you're a very nice person yes you are
very nice bye
so
and
it's finally happening dude this is so
close to falling apart okay okay i'm
sorry can i be honest though
i'm a little freaked out
like
i don't really understand what's going
on
this is what's going on we're gonna have
a drink and we're gonna talk
get to know each other
and then i am going to drive home
alone cool consider this ultra plan we
have drinks here get to know each other
whatever then we go back to my place
snuggle up like little bunnies yeah this
was a mistake no
oh hey boo boo bear
what did you just call me boo boo bear
it's one of several nicknames i made up
for you and you can choose which one you
like best cause i want this to be a give
and take okay we went out once and
nothing happened there is know this we
have cookie tush wow just right out the
gate winnie the boot liddy press brush
and berry sauce annie get your boo
tommy's girl annie benin hey
all right let's do this
what are you doing
is this not one of those
i might have misread the vibe oh my god
dude you have to be cooler about this
look i told leslie because she's my best
friend but
if anybody finds out about this and they
start jabbering it's gonna make it
really hard to know if this is
actually anything so
just
keep it on the dl okay i feel like
you're embarrassed by me that is
accurate
can we change my facebook status to in a
relationship definitely not
it's complicated
whatever am i in a relationship
it's complicated
is the coast clear what are you wearing
my sneak around closed is he gone yeah
he's gone come in you got to see this
tom and i have been seeing each other
for a few weeks and
i think i'm ready to say i love you
to his apartment i
love you
so much
look at all these blankets one on the
ottoman one on the chair one on the
couch here
holy hell that's soft
oh my god is that yep a whole shelf of
coconut water i think i'm gonna cry this
is like girl heaven did he do all of
this just for you no he just lives like
this he's deeply in debt but you know
what who cares cause check it out
cheese plate and adriatic figs leslie
this is always here i don't know when he
has time to make it boutique eye cream
unisex cologne lip exfoliator chocolate
covered almonds and a sudoku book just
amenities everywhere i love amenities i
know check this out this is the best
part 80 degrees night and day
ah look at this one there's another soft
one
you told april you were breaking up with
me and we consistently disagree on who
wore it best you still use an ipad one
you read books
all the time okay
how about my own no-no's for you you
make me see terrible movies and then you
talk through them you put 20-inch rims
on your volkswagen golf and you insist
on being introduced as the brown gosling
everything you just said makes me like
me
more i can't take it anymore okay i'm
breaking you up you guys are done fine
with me fine
oh april i'm drunk
you made me drunk you made me drunk
and you
nope nope give it a rest
i need it okay fine let's get you to bed
you know why are you guys even fighting
anyway it's so stupid i hate him because
of this stupid reason and i hate tom for
this stupid reason who cares april wake
up jerry's here mm-hmm april april hey
hi
why's your arm around her
i broke you up well we got back together
again because what you said what do you
mean i didn't say anything yeah when we
were carrying you to bed you correctly
pointed out that we were arguing about
stuff that was stupid and so we talked
it out and i apologize and he apologized
and now everything's great so thanks no
i'm drunk don't listen to me no
see out there no
but bobby newport is super handsome and
charming so that means people will
probably vote for him because there's no
justice in the world
how do you respond to newport's claim
that city parks need to be cleaned up
leslie knope works tirelessly every day
so our parks can be the best they can be
78 of pawnian's label are parks pristine
and we all know the better looking a
park is the more attention it will get
from lady parks who want to have sex
with it
excuse us
what the hell is wrong with you we're
fighting for our lives out there oh i
don't know maybe the fact that we just
broke up and you're already riding the
tracker train what are you talking about
i saw you guys getting back together
what about us what about us tom we're
not together anymore because you keep
acting like an ass
i'm sorry i just act that way sometimes
because i'm nervous and
i feel like you're out of my league
but i'd do anything to get back together
with you
please
vote for me to be your boyfriend
voter saw tonight is an undeniable fact
that one of these candidates is right
for this town and one of them is not
thanks guys
and perkins uh-oh
i'm sorry chris
it's very flattering i just i just don't
think it's a good idea
it was worth a shot
well i hope that whoever you end up with
treats you like the amazing person that
you are thank you and i am going to go
run some stairs and work through these
feelings
is he sad oh my god he looks sad i'm not
going out with chris again does that
mean we're getting back together no i
don't know no not right now there's a
chance i'm never gonna date anyone ever
again i'll take it
and you know what else
i'm coming for you girl
just like you won't just get out there
and spin man you got it
leslie knope is scrapping like a terrier
she's smooth
like a blended whiskey my girl has big
ideas and big feelings and she's not
afraid to express them tommy
this party was amazing you're amazing
you are ridiculous but i like you and i
think that we should date all of it
let's do it let's state this is my dream
nostrip thomas it's happening awesome
hey let's move in together
totally really yeah
all right no take backs when we sober up
though partner no take backs hard enough
i'm hungry my legs are tired
feels like i just exercise just sit on
the ground no jerry it's dirty and i'm
wearing my summer linens god you're such
a baby look i brought a picnic blanket
from your house that's not a picnic
blanket that's a merino wool throw for
my eem's chair
yeah do i sense trouble in the haverford
perkins household no such luck donna ann
and tom aka haverkins stronger than ever
everyone said it wouldn't last and it
didn't
shocking that our drunken plan to move
in together wasn't a success after the
first day we realized we had made a huge
mistake huge however everyone was being
so smug about it saying there's no way
it would last so we're pretending to
still be together that way no one gets
the satisfaction of being right even
though they are but still more
importantly i bet donna a thousand
dollars that we'd be together for
another month can't stress is enough if
she finds out that we broke up
i'll go bankrupt
you